let's say i'm trying to judge how many
years of experience we have at the khan
academy we're on average how many years
of experience we have and in particular
the particular type of average we'll
focus on is the arithmetic mean so i go
and i survey the folks there and let's
say this was when khan academy was a
smaller organization when there were
only five people in the organization and
i find and i'm surveying the entire
population so years of experience the
entire population of khan academy
because that's what i care about
years of experience at our organization
at khan academy this is when we had five
people and i were to go we're now 36
people i don't want to date this video
too much but let's say i go and i say
okay there's one person straight out of
college they have one year out of it one
year of experience or recently out of
college somebody with three years of
experience someone with five years of
experience someone with seven years of
experience and someone very experienced
or reasonably experienced with 14 years
of experience
so based on this data point and this is
our population for years of experience
i'm assuming that we only have five
people in the organization at this point
what would be the population mean for
the years of experience what is the mean
years of experience for my population
well we can just calculate that our mean
experience and i'm going to denote it
with mu because we're talking about the
population now this is a parameter for
the population
it's going to be equal to the sum
from our first data point so data point
one all the way to data point in this
case data point five we have five data
points of
of each of so we're going to take all
from the first data point the second
data point the third data point all the
way to the fifth so this is going to be
equal to x1
plus x and i'm going to divide it all by
the number of data points i have plus x2
plus x3 plus x4 plus
x sub 5 subscript 5 all of that over 5.
and as we said this is a very fancy way
of saying i'm going to sum up all of
these things i'm going to sum up all of
these things and then divide by the
number of things we have so let's do
that
get the calculator out
so i'm going to add them all up
so i'm going to add them all up 1 plus 3
plus 5. i really don't need a calculator
for this plus
seven plus fourteen
so that's five data points and i'm gonna
divide by five and i get six
so the population mean for years of
experience at my organization is six six
years of experience well that's i guess
interesting but now i want to ask
another question i want to get some
measure of how how much spread there is
around that mean or how much do the data
points vary around that mean and
obviously i can give someone all the
data points but instead i actually want
to come up with a parameter that somehow
represents how much all of these things
on average are varying from this from
this number right here or maybe i will
call that thing the variance
and so what i do
so the variance
variance and i will do this is a
population variance that i'm talking
about just to be clear it's a parameter
the population variance i'm going to
denote with the greek letter sigma
lowercase sigma this is capital sigma
lowercase sigma
squared and i'm going to say
well i'm going to take the distance from
each of these points to the mean and
just so i get a positive value i'm going
to square it and then i'm going to
divide by the number of data points that
i have so essentially i'm going to find
the average squared distance now that
might sound very complicated but let's
actually work it out so i'll take my
first data point
i'll take that data point and i will
subtract our mean from it so this is
going to give me a negative number but
if i square it it's going to be positive
so it's essentially going to be the
square distance between 1 and my mean
and then to that i'm going to add the
squared distance between 3 and my mean
and my mean
and to that i'm going to add the squared
distance between 5 and my mean
5 and my mean and since i'm squaring it
doesn't matter if i do 5 minus 6 or 6
minus 5. when i square it i'm going to
get a positive result regardless and
then to that i'm going to add the
squared distance between 7 and my mean
so 7 minus 6 squared all of this this is
my population mean that i'm finding the
difference between and then finally the
squared the squared difference between
14 and my mean plus
and
my mean and then i'm going to find
essentially the mean of these squared
distances so this i have 5 squared
distances right over here so let me
divide
let me
let me divide by 5. so what will i get
when i make this calculation right over
here
well let's figure this out this is going
to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 1 minus 6
is negative 5. negative 5 squared is 25
3 minus 6 is negative 3 if i squared
that i get 9.
5 minus 6 is negative 1. if i square it
i get positive 1.
7 minus 6 is 1. if i square it i get a
positive 1. and 14 minus 6 is 8 if i
square it i get 64.
and then i'm going to divide that by i'm
going to divide all of that
by
5. and i don't need to use a calculator
but i tend to make a lot of careless
mistakes when i do things
while i'm making a video so let me get i
get 25 plus 9 plus 1 plus 1
plus 64
divided by 5 divided by 5. so i get 20.
so the average squared distance or the
mean squared distance from our
population mean
is equal to
is equal to 20. you might say wait these
things aren't 20 way remember it's the
squared distance away from my population
mean so i squared each of these things i
liked it because it made it positive and
we'll see later it has other nice
properties about it
now the last thing is how can we
represent this mathematically we already
saw that we represent we know how to
represent a a population mean and a
sample mean mathematically like this and
hopefully we don't find it that daunting
anymore but how would we do the exact
same thing how would we denote what we
did right over here
well let's just think it through we're
just saying that the population variance
the population variance we're taking the
sum we're taking the sum
the sum
of each so we're going to take each item
we'll start with the first item and
we're going to go to the nth item in our
population this is we're talking about
the population here
and we're going to take we're not going
to just take the item we're not this
would just be the item but we're going
to take the item and from that we're
going to subtract the population mean
we're going to subtract this thing we're
going to subtract this thing
we're going to square it
we're going to square it so the way i've
written it right now this would just be
the numerator i've just taken the sum of
each of these things the sum of the
difference between each data point and
the population mean and squared it if i
really want to get the way i figured out
this variance right over here i have to
divide the whole thing by the number of
data points we have
so this might seem very daunting and
very intimidating but all it says is
take each of your data points
well one it says figure out your
population mean
figure out your prop population
figure that out first
and then from each from each data point
in your in your population subtract out
that population mean square it take the
sum of all of those things and then just
divide by the number of data points you
have and you will get your population
variance